and joining us now are cbs news
political analyst and president trump's
former white house chief of staff
reince priebus and cbs news political
contributor and democratic strategist
joel payne good morning to both of you
gentlemen
sometimes after a debate there is a
split between what the professional
pundits are saying and what the general
public is saying but here we have a poll
showing that most viewers
thought it was negative and they used
the word annoying rights to you first
i'm curious
how do you describe it
well i don't think too many people are
probably moved by it i think
personally i think president trump would
have been better by
allowing joe biden just to speak and
melt and you know the few times he did
try to
speak and he did speak i don't think he
did particularly well around the crime
bill and other topics but
look i i also saw some analysis where
one third
of the people out there thought trump
won one third thought biden won and
one-third said that they're going to
stay home which is
great for you know the president it's
bad for a challenger but
i think the name calling you know biden
saying shut up
and racist and liar and clown i don't
think served anyone well and i think it
happened on both sides
yeah right a little too hot uh probably
but
i also think it's reflective of the
country i think that that's where
the country is at and people are people
are fired up and i think you saw that
last night yeah right
it's quite a commentary when you say
it's good for the president if people
don't show up at the polls
that says a lot i want to go to you joel
well it's hey guess what it's politics
it's called politics and i think people
are fed up by that
typically you would say i'm a popular
candidate i want everyone to have their
say and therefore i will be chosen but
what you're saying is it's good for the
president if people are turned off
that's just an interesting point of view
from a political campaigning standpoint
joel to you do you agree with the
majority of viewers who were really
turned off by the tone last night
last night was a debate where you needed
tequila nearby to get through that
debate that was difficult
i only felt bad for one person there it
was the moderator and it was the people
having to watch at home
this was american carnage and i think
what i'm hearing from people is
they're just ready to get off the roller
coaster and they know who's at the front
of the roller coaster who's causing all
of it and it's donald trump
and his strategy was clear to try to
obfuscate
and try to distract and to try to throw
joe biden off of his game
and i think all he ended up doing was
really presenting a microcosm of the
last three and a half years
which is chaos which is a lack of plan
and which is a lack of any desire to
bring the country together
so if the if the whole point here is
addition and is to bring coalitions
together
i don't think donald trump did that i
think joe biden sure there were some
uneven moments
but overall he tried to reach out to new
voters and he tried to broaden his
coalition
and ultimately that's what you're trying
to do when you're trying to win
elections
well a group by the name of proud boys
is certainly doing the hula today they
even have a new slogan thanks to
president trump last night
so this question is for both of you but
reince i want to start with you
you know the president talks endlessly
about all the work that he does for
black americans in this country and the
support that he has and he's done more
for
black americans since president lincoln
yet he refuses to condemn
white supremacists of this white
supremacist group
writes why is it so difficult for him to
do that
i i i don't honestly gail i i don't know
who
proud boys are if and if you're saying
what they are then yeah they should be
condemned i don't know who they are but
if
you are then yes i would i would
this is really really important i'm not
asking if you know who they are i'm
asking you
as someone who knows president trump
very well
why it's so hard for him the president
of the united states
to condemn a white supremacist group i
know you know what white supremacist
means
someone said to me this morning it's
like if you say to a guy listen are you
against
men abusing women and you go well what
kind of abuse is it
it doesn't matter the name of the group
he is refusing to condemn white
supremacy
why is that so hard for the president of
the united states
and everybody always dodges and tiptoes
around the question
you know him intimately i just want your
help has i mean i've been in
press conferences when he has i mean
i've seen him
say it repeatedly so you know he's
condemned many
white supremacist groups and again gail
you're going to
ask the person that you're asking the
question to it you're not asking me
you're asking the president you're going
to have to ask him but as far as the
debate is concerned you know i
i personally totally missed that with
all the shouting back and forth i didn't
even hear that part
yeah of the debate well that that's
there a lot of presidents a lot of
people did hear it
but that's very few minutes this was a
thing this morning that's been
spurring up that that you know i've just
picked up on but okay
i'm gonna you're probably gonna ask the
president i would imagine he's going to
be asked the question gail and i might
guess what
is going to condemn these white
supremacist group i mean i've seen him
do it before and i think right now
as a lifelong republican i would think
you would want to ask the president
gail i don't know what he heard or what
i didn't know i don't even
okay i don't even know what he heard or
what he knew okay
i think you have to look at hbcus you
have to look at i would think done on
the crime
on on first step back then you have to
look at what he's done on black and
employment pre-pandemic and look at the
results and then you have to look at
what joe biden did in supporting
the 1994 crime bill well then it
shouldn't be hard for him to condemn
white supremacist judges it shouldn't be
hard for him to do it and again
i don't know what's going on i hear you
i hear you
i hear you right i hear you tony joel
you were saying
no i was saying i didn't miss it um and
you know look right um
i i i like right and i think that the
difficulty he's having speaking for the
president today is the difficulty a lot
of republicans are going to have up and
down the ballot
over the next month if you're susan
collins in maine if you're corey gardner
if you are tom tillis in north carolina
this is who you have to run with
and this is the problem that donald
trump is creating is that he's forcing
these people to make a decision do i run
with the president and yes he's heating
up the base
and you're going to have a lot of
republican turnout but there's no effort
to reach out i heard john dickerson
earlier
you cannot win elections by only heating
up your base and not
bringing out people from the middle the
president hasn't done that and it's
going to cost
let me just say this no no republicans
no republicans support these white
supremacist group
i don't support them i never did when i
was party chairman
i don't agree with anything that they're
that they're doing
i think they're fringe people i don't
think you can win elections with these
people so
will the president condemn them today
will the president condemn them today
again okay we gotta we gotta go we have
to ask him i'm sure he will
we got to go i would think we'll because
he's done it before the question is why
he didn't last night and i would think
you would want to ask him as a lifelong
republican
the proud boys we got to go to we got to
go to break here i want to point out the
proud boys describe themselves as a
western chauvinist organization
refused to apologize for creating the
modern world that is the the
vow that members take i'm a western
chauvinist who refuses to apologize
for creating the modern world thank you
both clearly there's a lot more to
discuss